[music]
[applause]
university without labor remote without taking game of
base
uchas
[music]
welcome to the studio got in touch with
you or mira skripchenko evgenia
miroshnichenko
and we will comment on the second
day of the final tournament in london grant
clean files yes good afternoon good evening
dear friends, I understand that for
the majority of viewers of the Russian broadcast
Evening will give nevertheless and then 2 2
classic game of semi-final matches
in london let's remind probably
let's start with that generally recall the mouse too
how are our matches going because
already
including the commentator themselves and here I am on
I'll take responsibility
the error said that everything in the classics can
decide in the classics to play very
a lot of points but still the match is only in
it is impossible to win classical games
and so two classical parties are played
the first has already ended in a draw in both
matches yesterday yes for each in each
Classical Party Played 6
points for the victory of the classical game male
go 6 points ahead, it's doubled
more than i got
playing your last tournament 6 points
this is an oma service before after which that is
two games will be played tomorrow
in rapid chess wrapped
and four parties in the face in quick
chess game is worth 4 points 4 for a win
two by two in case of a draw and by 2
point system play blitz so easy
for convenience so as not to mess with
halves decided to increase even in blitz
the number of points we will play in each
school desk, respectively, if today u
someone wins us in the class
suppose yes i.e. it is six points
leadership but still possible
win back because the last day
is played, it turns out 8 points in two
rapid
eight points 4 blitz well, not with us
already your ritual let's look at
tournament schedule yes yes schedule of the day
2 classic party and tomorrow will be
played out
games of rapid chess and blitz
and then we have an unexpected day off
ok then a day off for not so much u
how many players we have, as I understand it, yes
no one will leave the London tournament want
it would seem that the elimination game is on
survival but will be played and a match for
third place yes just I wanted
clarify that the match will be played for the third
the place where the losers in the semi-finals are all
will remain in London on 5 December
something really there to mark it 6 return to
olympia hall london where actually
passes passes the tournament what is the prize
fund let's see if we have
this slide recall yes there does not have
it makes sense to play, including for the third
place match difference between third and
fourth prize printer for everyone
$20,000 total prize case
$350,000 fund
150 for the first place 100 for the second such
here is a good addition to
pensions, yes, besides, let me remind you, yes, we
there considered the total prizes of Magnus already
earn somewhere a quarter of a million before
the end of the chair yes and that's the case let's say
wins in the tournament another 150 thousand well
now I greet everyone in the chat on
our screens will now appear
I think this is the official hashtag
a good edge often appeared with us and
new hashtag 10 files also on youtube and
on the verge of frequent dot org
husky and wolf and you will teach and call
michelle fan asparagus and
agency that we have a lot of tin and
replacing like this hello everyone and waiting
your questions
logic us cosyns called david talk
in all possible languages ​​yes to us
reminds that it would be nice to remind about
participants of the dac tournament even after all
still playing on tour
this is how we see the stage is still empty despite
to the fact that in 5 minutes it seems they should
start well let's look at
prepared here are the cards of the players and
Let's start with magnus carlsen
such an imposing Norwegian man
impressive results this year
the only one in quotation marks failing
st louis rapid and blitz tournament where am i
in my opinion 8 attributed yesterday 6 actually
actually took the place that of course according to him
standards are still indecently low
place no less but how did he play it
the opponent of those tournaments is see the maxim
earring
Maxim was selected in fact only
thanks to the victory in paris
the rest of the results are not so bad
Rapid blitz in Ivory Coast
and in St. Louis, but that's a classic at all
didn't go to Maxim both times divided 9 1
developed 11 format yes we had two
classic tournament and its qualifying
the place was literally hanging by a thread, we all
followed the tournament in India of course
commented
with us for the second week and we saw
how much did Vishy Anand try to qualify
finna year arnie in london but he doesn't have
turned out and look at the statistics
meetings between themselves so 82 leads to
classic chess
magnus carlsen at the grand hour tour both
games in the classics won this year and
in croatia and in st louis at the single cup
yes, well, it turns out we have some
disagreement with the American studio in
classics they have plus 9 maybe we
we can make it all the same
some clarity actually 8 world
witnessed another victory for Magnus
baskets of maxims that happened
remember where you are still at when where 2006
year it was a rapid chess tournament
since and involved played from those
chew on leaves in the sun
confirm that this is a batch
the number of classic meetings will not go
well, what appeared on your screens
malcolm taeyang main organizer of the tournament
london chess classic
and now the edge feeling files rather
just by tradition, he calls the players to
scene do you think or not, I don't know
frankly, there is no tradition nor was on
tournaments in London, yes, judging by
all players must already be in the tournament
hall and at the same time they don’t sit at the tables
most likely really to this
procedure that's like fighters in the ring
cause this is the second tournament in a row
which takes place in a very beautiful hall in
india as we saw the participants met
applause as they climbed
scene again the tournament enjoys great
popular and in London a lot
spectators in the hall
yes come on sorry for interrupting let's not
forget we somehow concentrated
on Coruscant I somehow forgot not not
manages to insert 5 cents before let's not
forget because in another
semi-final pair we play the same day
which I will remind
beat Magnus Carson did not beat in
personal meeting but beat on a tie-break
in the same sen field to buy sinful
until quite confidently selected one
not even well, if you look no
failed performances yes that is
adequately played cowon plays very smoothly
in all tournaments and, accordingly, the second
place in the qualifying round according to the results of the overall
selection yes once it seems to me he is not
was approaching there was no chance that she was driving
mama bent but never seriously well under
the threat was not his own place in
final and his opponent Levon Aronian
let's look at levon and now
must show the lego card
some kind of lemon here are polar
performances, that is, two first places in
uh quick tournaments up to 3 4 in classic in
croatia and 2 absolute dividing failures
the last single in the cup and the same there
what is the third from the end in tata steel
india here is the tournament which ended in
coma there is not 10 but for
yes we have a small graphics error
appeared of course did he take third
place in general position verge hour tour
that's why he's third in london
seeded played to second base
yes and cover in tempo 7 same upholstery
was automatically done in this tournament then
there is 1 in 0 4 2 out of 3 yes but also like this
we were shown house 0 and that it's time to
Tournament for already coming last here
graphics on a personal account up to plus 3 1 a
Aronian did not lose to you in any of the desks
in the classics this year both meetings
ended nothing, well, let's
let's follow the tournament hall den & ryan already
took their places it is not clear whether in place
2 parades are also in place traditionally
first move symbolic first move
makes whoever gatchina muffins are always children
it seems to me that gerber students taught
chess academies
what a move was made for money
Dean's life was done and 4 curious
will this move actually take place yes
I remember yesterday if you remember the final moment
when I swung there in my opinion they did
it's my mother's fault 2033 went to for
marriage to the very still shock I have
so a little speculate about what
debuts are waiting for us today, about dina
I don't understand at all because I think
and 4 the Chinese chess player just doesn't move
it's hard to remember the game wherever the general
she is 4 then usually all the same cool english
beginning of summer and water 4 as a reference too than
yes, and for the maxim we went d4, this is also with
highly likely this move
Maxim will change and in this pair I am not
I rule out that we can see the second
Sicilian yes yesterday if you remember
played a variant bustard and pretty
curious party such where both
chess player, as already shown by analysis
after the games both played very well
if we have a moment maybe i
even go back to this party both played
did very well
the strongest codes to the big one out there actually
unmistakable party while having
absolutely wrong to say
the motivation of those interviews there it transpired
then look 45 will I marry you
there is an option everyone said to be
we have a chance for a second sicily but no
did not take place mac os decided after all
answer e5 and knight c6
spanish party we have service here 5
quite expected move from maxim
then magna will play, then after all
black strategies on equations me
it seems in this party and understandable men
simply
Well, show me, I don't know what is playing in
august because let's say he might
play and berlin if so if at all
let's look at the equation which option
still choose the world champion
fairly diverse bieber
repertoire you even post after move 5 yeah
that is, if you remember the counterattack
marshal magnus played played and what i wanted
tell them before the move was made
ultimate played variant breyer 1
multiple systems castling here
there when the cubes are 8 black and now
the so-called open variant is played
Spanish game with a capture on e4 and we
Let's see if it's open here too
space for theoretical discussions
here is the move of the elephants this is something for
me brand new to be honest
still would be 5 to 5 yes of course not
let's see agnes lately
very often surprises his rivals on
homeland standing at an early stage he
playing new schemes it doesn't seem like he
actually started preparing for
title defense match
but which will it seem to me to be
organized a year later in 2020
even we have a question appeared in the chat
do we think that he will be able to defend his
title and
well, it seems to me that we need us for now
same
well, you have a clear feeling that
here in this let's say in this for this magnus
don't lose or or in turnover lose
or or what will be very wobbly you know
I understand no I think it's the other way around
magnus is so versatile now
plays his parts so well
just amazing i think
he is so strong
it is at this moment that he transcends
all your rivals
but it seems to me that the Candidates Tournament
throughout the history of chess on history will
surpass us in strength all the tournaments well
here it is difficult to temporary is not difficult to say
because there was
fantastic client tournament in london
where can it be considered
the strongest wanted because he played there
max london himself 13 years old yes it is clear that
were but in general tournament and subjects
weak it won't be stellar will
composition and very curious of course who
will get but here I have enough too
here is a strong feeling that in this cycle
the crown will remain Norway
where will it remain as technically for a long time
did not come from norway so yes if
this is the physical corona
piece of iron this from where to go to
Oslo well let's see Magnus already
actually played like that today
hookah in grant raster in croatia in
classical tournament you just need to
I don’t remember the classic, yes, we forgot, yes
so much party has been played in this
listen to the truth, they finished the game then sony
seven rooks 151 were ready strange
option was in paid money 4d 5d 4 before
5 5 5 kunka not 5 rook 5 4 at the end of 32
0 would be three in my opinion before the meal as there is not
one rook was not chosen in this game
fabiana where one bishop to 65 this position
I remember yes, that is, this position on
actually played here for some reason
for some reason it is dangerous to pick up on foot and
as far as I remember when 5 is an elephant before 6
just playing and somehow very awkward
say fall back on and one then this one
position for black good servants around
somewhere I wish after d5 everything is even
due to the fact that there are only 2 pawns
remained on the royal yes that is not
quite comfortable feel corrosion and
despite the presence of multicolored
elephants the presence of a heavy figure in this
it seems to me that positions are guaranteed by black
very good breasts even fight for
conveys that they just transferred a knot, but
see levon aronian vs omidyar chakra
elected him
instead of a horse c3 two bo3 no without food
offer deed one and on f6 villains 35 played
on media rafi this game was won with black
1006 lags and 375
in general played yes let's go back then
actually to the position on the board after the bishop
e7 that is, yes, this is not exactly news
so they play and then we'll wait for the response
move from maxim so far we can look at
the second game of wipe the rights was played
Hikaru on Como vs Fabio on Knuda
if you get this position and go under
the composition is obtained in principle
forced don't know lately
white only and only so the game only
so u play up i suggest to watch
for the second batch there was some
I have hope that after all in the second
the games of this semi-final will start already
such a full blooded fight yesterday levon
Well, you can say not exactly played
for a draw with white, well, not the best one
the fundamental option was chosen quite
quickly the party ended with nothing then
lamented that it was not quite good
felt like levon mine
yes they are let's see what's on the board
udino motion and levon aronian while behind
almost 3 were played with non-savich shields
short castling knight f3 well like this
non-obvious actually
a set of moves and so hesitantly enters
burdens me usually you turn in
some on Indian constructions no
after how flow c5 is this present
so to speak, the protection of the German of the evening is here
one can say that in principle
white the same position more often many points
starting with lords 35 knight f3 yes like this
because knight f3 you are absolutely right
gives black additional opportunities
here to play pool b6 or even kanye 4
here is a variant of such a weasel 4 months 2
to all f5 then somewhere big bishop to
7th so try to part
there is such there is really good and y
we got c5 sunderen and right here
the fundamental position of course is this
move up to 75 short knight c6 a3 take on
zither to play this position is the most difficult
before either 2 there is a possibility it is dc and horse
d7 was also played as far as I remember before
1 second 7 is up to target elephant up to 7 here
even the move played by Vishy Anand
a lot of opportunity we're here any
selects such a garden and dd5 jump to
somehow I started building rather here
from the pan to receive from the attack on the new
karaka not in general and all kinds of positions
with an isolated pawn it would seem
position on possibly still from exchange
French
French change here on foot and 6
worth no when eating food before
consistently expound and flax because
what is it all the same it looks more like
on all sorts of here or there accepted
queen year after meant that
after cd knight t5 this position to me
seems to have played there far and wide
yes, that is, a position with an isolated
pawn
here it’s like 4 sometimes there is smart and 7
it is worth taking a pawn from a lemon
just c before meals
the short word is 4 in such constructions
but as a rule, whites have some
little little plus because
that complete symmetry would seem to have killed them
due to the right ledge rushed from s ii
plus
Bishop e7 would have 4 bishops standing on 4 they
somewhere you need 6 or 7, probably a little
will fall under the awning through the battle of
case then serve 4 most likely at least
Ukrainians because in this position they are white
Often
jumps on and 5 yeah that's get to know
6 almost immediately you can even walk at
she's 5 yes, these are the days it seems to me well
let's say at the level of the idea, yes, at least weasels
5 is quite entitled to
existence is what black beat like
the rule here is inconvenient and hangs on
f6 yes that is there after to the tip below 4
you can indulge like that t5 you can
take to move through to 5 take our
7 to a take on de-4 that's what will lead
I don’t know such an elephant’s position for everyone
king or to them there black prince b4
again here's how another party lest that one
the fact that one of the king's pawns
flank black exchanged i think that
may not be very successful white
it's developing very fast here.
elephant same 5 she d1 getting so nice
nice position with initiative yes because
that he is 4 competently on the move as many as twice
if it is played
do not change go our 5 to 6 to
sensations yes here I started the quality of white
the acceptance of whites is more pleasant, but for
this here is the symmetry due to the potentials to
size black stays there 99 percent
case I thought there is such an idea in
exchange in french while ours was shaking ours 5
is it possible to play the same 4k by myself
six-pointed icon 5 urgently
weakens
significantly kingside on such
ideas present before you're right here
black ones have time to exchange 3 st3
through d3 yes and we will say bye to play
cavalry 6 question how scared i am
probably elephant same 5 before connection because
the point here is that, as a rule,
if the fabric is left on and 5 then this is an attempt
here the horse was shot down and there to support
its a pawn in 4 to go but here it's quite
bad because black is exchanging
and he puts his knight on e4 structurally
this is for black people quite well
acceptable position another question
some options here exiled j5 with
the pin of this knight f6 must be considered
and here black will have to somehow
be careful can be
retreat by and 7 or maybe even
move marten 6 is no longer just what i mean
I think again if you play this on
hang up maybe i can do it myself
take on c3 bc suspect up to tulle
Daroy said and now put the horse on and 4
so that there are no all these bundles of knives 5 yes
and if suddenly they chase me in the course and in
third can be if necessary 6 like them
busy don't feel like don't want c4
but here here what is the same as dancing or
346 then and also it is not clear how much
how black I am afraid of this
I think you might know
start with some nice moves then
younger would be alone while she would be all over the place
on occasion there will be an addition such as
3 fixed it will be able to attack somewhere there
on on songs on f7
manage to bring about some kind of recovery
praise yes well, while it is far from that
the situation on the board is thinking dean
directly after bishop g4
that nadia and one end part i like
already the question is whether we can collect queen b3
I understand that this is allowed by the exchange in
take captivity immediately and I won't be on f3
scary proper tanning would 4
programming if here end 6
like marten 5 I managed to bounce off
this exchange on f3 then and 5 here me
it seems white is just decent
better, well, there is a chance already
address sent yes i think so
the critical option here would be 33
slum byd f3 and here is the question is it possible
well, that is probably possible and necessary
try to take to the pool
which can lead to some very
merry you can't plant and what
area can lead to
whatever serves you like the king is alive
just and here they are somehow game when
Kozitsyn wanted it himself two fillets for 8
like taking f1 and first not at all
confident in my calculations again all the same
time will be expelled laden
don't hear in me don't like it very much
queen 8 because before black is just
they will take it to f1 and honestly they are on fire even here
in this position even if there through
bass is not good
actually this is also unclear
also unclear because he gave white
some structural defects, but two
elephant and bye
ahead in development there on everything
suspension and not so easy in this position
actually get to the king and here
let's suppose white managed like a 4 bishop
same 3 play such a house built
not not very clear yes bottom clear
when the king get to
this might be enough
promising line has done wrong
just see it doesn't feel otherwise
classic almost white especially 2 y
it has its own specifics, I remember in due time
when we played just started to play
world championships according to the olympic system
i.e. when you play two
classic party in case that 11
heated project sat draw black while
then did not know how
mentally prepare for the game
white and
grandmaster very often you said
looks like it's not that easy to make
it's white because you seem to be
must try to defeat the opponent
white party on the other side
psychologically
it's not so easy to overcome yourself and then and
during during curl up play on
draw to
yes here we have it all the same again
Remind you that it doesn't end
classic match so here a little bit
Less pressure seems to me yes of course
lose the classic game again and
with white it's a huge six-point handicap
difference, but it's still possible
it is quite possible to try and even in the case
defeat then there is a distance to
win back quick blitz which option
chose maxi
maxi will andrian return and this one
theoretical discussion we fight to the party
entered logrov carson not yet what
I chose the variant of the book, you know
after he sat down there he played day 1 then
we have reached this position
which was actually discussed by computer 5
until here by the way absolutely we are not
discussed what would happen if you take Ali's rook
nothing will happen, just pick up here
bullied 7 then you can’t
she has 5 knights 5 rooks 5 because that's all
played and here as we found out here
the whole set of moves exists and b2b 3 yes
and queens 1 and knight c3 again b2b 3
from a strategic idea, it seems to me
if in this position White exchanges with
floor elephants while maintaining
pawn on d5 of course their position will be
very nice yes and after b3 by the way what
move me like a servant 6 he remembers misfortunes
yes, because if you play a short
castling then probably clicked get dressed
Yes, I'm right here somewhere
it seems to me to run into trouble
that owns 737 like 3 yes yes who
running into trouble here outcome
some serve 4 maybe have a move
come on so sketchy come on
suppose black is just there
agrees to some sizes there
pick up on
this is an incredibly nasty position
that is, a b a b on d5 there is an elephant hanging there i 6
and white horses start to move 4 somewhere
cavalry 5 i.e. it's probably even that
may not
crayfish i think i need it is false
monument, even something I saw in
fast river then play remind it
won such a position against hikaru no
usually, of course, by a thread, too, in this
party and again I don't know what
cooked magnus in this position on
what scheme is he going to go for
let's say after bo3 on the look at the choice itself
how big yes not so big
scatter of options, that is, most likely yes
it's in some kind of set of elephant i 6
short castling is just a rebound game
still very curious that in the case of the end
3 happens most likely
fundamental move because here
already black actually owes the pawn
victim before and after castling short well
so it's not obvious there and the rook d5 is possible
consider and calmly icon 4 that is
in this in this case up get black
so consonant with the marshal's counterattack
compensation vt5 like fb3 that's very accurate
the move was made by fabian bishop 6 before castling
see means
forbid to take it and this all the same, yes, but
let's go over this batch of it
nakamura caruana from simka fruit cup
classic this year this year on
to comment and then live
just hikaru with layer 6 was played
like three elephants three horses you see
happens but the knight hits 3 i.e.
all the same
and castling is a little more successful for
black editions and then white is nothing more
they didn’t come up with smart as soon as they didn’t
cooling down 16 d6 exact move nc3
and bbc 5 here in would and myself I live
she built this position and in principle
I think it's smart enough
some moment and he is in my opinion with us
shared that the deal is an inaccuracy already
then again the knight barely f6
well, maybe something like this
position yes here black at least
manage to push through 5 yes. not four
foot care one hour very specifically before
struggled with the plan number late 5 and
until the rook is still stable on g5
of course he used this moment
this case b3 case cavalry 3
something else is going on
Magnus' party was up to Magnus' map
let's get back to parties agnes that is
injured wonder what
Aronian like an hour to another Finn and yes
will help how I nose yes against magnus
knight played c3 and here is castling here
it's a pawn sacrifice than to take or not to take
what did you decide almost without knowing what
let's decide not to run over stupid come on
let me see the behavior of the community
blacks have problems even without being themselves
let me check if there were almost
I'm sure I saw something to take and on
Rack for example skates 5.5 no one beat
then jump bragare just before
position
rook d5
hard to believe people don't play like that
5 were fingers distant 8 sixth year
krupa won vasily ivanchuk you know
well let's see how u debuts 1 before
Salon 5 to 6 he beat with White in
championship of the soviet union
at one time owned 5 to 6 elephant same 5 here
so here it was made from and party
again, one can doubt
I know why not in 6 queens 80 grams
Vasilyev chuk and White played a3
why not at 6 f6 lunar 4d who
not a button accordion, honestly, I even thought about
immediate care as if in 4
and that's when I'm like this arises to this
position black most likely sim service
play up to volume need 6 cd and white extra
a pawn but that's how this rook dangles
here it is not clear where it is on f5 our
imagine yes that is probably on this
somehow compensation is being built for what it is
almost certainly base very little don't know
what's with the sandman's perry we can again
we are visible
diligently studying the bases yet bye bye
do not start insulin at all sooner
Total
won't go back to his old one until rook d5
mecum maxim feels everything very well
initiative and I'm not sure that he
wants to play and position after get along
torment Magnus again after b3 to me
it even seems very nice maybe like you
think positional wait come on
still show how kronos played
carlson can after coins 3 short
castling that villain one was played
yes yes lydia one elephant to 6 level li
you from 0 to 6 and ladies went slando 6 and
fabiana went fast and furious 5 he stripped lunge
ether for four blacks, that is, here I am
I liked this move visage 5 queens already 5 off
records 5b here it was again what
hard enough to go for mine with an ambassador
would be 4 log would be 8 what would it be to bring 8
rook abedin water and 8.5 pawn down but i
I remember that here the KPS has special problems
there didn’t seem to be blacks, well, once in a while
this key as it was played to me that is
once again back to all three short gave
11 is not completely clear what is all the same
ambassador would be 4 there, well, probably a little
just passive landscape 55 30 to 5 both
slambed volodya b8 d1 water and 8 june 3
played white, it seems to you that
she's so easy to play with
even with two elephants they are just
it’s enough to be younger by 5 something like that in
who is not yet on Carson's not the best
acted surprisingly
well, here is an illustration of a thin
knowledge of psychology
Skripchenko who guessed what would happen
played b2b 3
know what's curious on b3 carson
reacted by short castling
and own the texting game on was not and here I am
I suspect this is the one
which I found sent 3 is
some lunge bishop g4
which may not be clear why
video on most likely party will come from
permutation of hatts the same position after
b3
if not takes based on 6 most likely
nothing better even I try all the same
understand and why on and 7 did not take because
what happened then the transition to
party to party proper nakamura
caruana was founded like a 3 elephant somewhere
3 conchita 3 no know don't don't go
it seems he is not 6 well then yes services 6 on
move empty instead play put it down
creating some tension to jump on
the horse is terrible at 300 we are good what to do
white here
and such a move as a frieze 1 st because just
I thought about it and then I'm the only queen
I understand that black he and 5 play
because the whites themselves tied everything up by
lines and black play he them 5 but here
it is important to leave the knight on 3 not to give
white I wanted to regroup
in some strange way
rearrange this mix so as not to
protect the rook on 5 wanted to go after
queens one movie for 5 maybe
of course this is the specifics of queens of 7 nations
wait, well, maybe you can take it here
I don’t understand, you happen like this
up to 5 own up to 8 now knight on 3
defend but can be played from 3 to dealt
say that black is in perfect order
after 5 there is some more funny
option can take on 3 and take on 2 to
which is also unlikely to win but
at least amuse the public
through beta 2 probably just white
retreat there together f1 is also not particularly
sad because the entrance e6 there is everything
so I suspect that the full complete order
how did it happen to my database
but that means while we digress the world and
the studio computer turned off so
while the update on the theoretical
discussion yes and will not be given actually
in fact, there is already some position on them
relatively fresh
to start yes it is necessary to warn all the same
it will be necessary there of course it will be necessary
restore but we will live somehow to
first break restored
restore modified studio 2
so far I only have a computer
left a computer with an analytical board
let's not use it here
moment of course by hello to all
in the chat are very glad that you are with us and Zhenya
especially despite the fact that the doctor
morning till evening let's see what
come up with a reason if you don't give me how
face words before that's what I tried
to say that the position is fresh for us
position fresh obviously for moms for maxim
but not for cardboard which 2:10
that is, until everything goes according to magnus wai
serious training here's the way the game is on
scored a victory honestly then don't give
it tells me that I'm not
looked through the games for 13 years was like this
party of beams of rajabs we are yet
still going that's why
continues to continue on theory
that is, the modern theory is not
how much will magnus improve the game
black or maxim's shield coarsened ah here
come on let's get distracted even from the party
about the way look at the position no no
I'm not entirely clear here are the guidelines
it seems that you should not allow white
own 5 diet either bit again
figure if it succeeds either immediately
change to and 8 may be such an attempt
swap for and 8 play knights b1 and that's it
how to catch it on the zither if
not queens alone i want to try again
62 and built all the same then translate
horse vladi unity offer zid wa as if
glassmaking 11 to now me
have to beat 35 and I'm still version 5
on a break 6 yes, that is, it seems to me
it is important that I keep the c2 pawn in sight
then I agree with what you hold on
sight and then go to this edition
all four are a bad but it's not bad but i
it seems then black has no special
cause for concern if I say
exchanged on b3 exchanged on c4 and
whites here too
such a strange choice because
Well, beat on the structure, I want to drink Toby
be a pawn put d5 yes well then
remains absolutely terrible horse but on
and if you take it with a horse, I don’t really understand
why should black have at least
some problems don't get away in a horse
pawns but more or less adequately weak and
other teeth that is black at least a shadow
problems if the uterus of the latter is not
get there for me 6 complete order
look when his sympathy is on the beard
squeeze to them bye bye give me it seems
so it was played in this game against
rajaba on the other side seems to me
that's it timur he is so good
knows the positions he plays and again
here is the psychological
magna most likely goes to the position to be
maybe a little you want most likely u equals and
knows how to do it said nothing
just before the party that he most likely
will play for the equation with black
so the Yankee style was chosen by me but what
I don't really know because
it doesn't seem black at all
enough to tell me
fight for the upper hand it would be
too loud statement but create
some kind of tension
which means it allows White on occasion
make a mistake and what if we're here now
just make a couple of developmental moves
get this pair position from the batch
pockets vs nakamura nakamura vs
except for nakamura played white in which well
here we can clearly say the game is coming on
2 result i.e. cool try
black most likely saved one chance
black to actually play for a win
are zero yes look at you alone
strategic plan this position like me
can hinder him
36 I thought then the white Zaydi was not like that
Doctor Harmonious Headphones Queen Need
two ropes an arrow and one then a boat about
let when you have time you can do something
here try to do this to play with him
seek and finally 3 from the rhythm of the page and that's about
what kind of things am I talking about when
I'm telling black to create strategic
a clue to play to win could be
it's just a weak pawn I'm not sure but
while she is alive on 3 black has
there is some kind of perspective
seem good so on that is white
probably not too much here
frustrated they go camping and alone
put it on e3 and there somehow f3 or h3
Well, as a standard game, I suspect
it doesn't matter if black has problems sooner or
start late well, here's the heart 62 yeah well
i.e. it's not too late again it's not too late
exchange then maybe on air c6
really don't need
[music]
curious do you know what's in the other party
Isn't it really a shed for us there
produces nothing for us we have seen
position there approaches serve 4 there
quite a lot of time dean spent
played h3 and that's it and after that it doesn't go
so we must because we can absolutely
stay calm showing Magnus parties
fillet
maxim
so once again we said exchange and 8
queens 8 and the knight would be one yes and here
maybe black is needed
somehow smarter to act can be
somehow smarter to act as black
maybe hold c5 in for a while
while the white horse brings us three to the
first 6 move on one side
attractive, yes
stop the appearance of the knight at 3 but
we get on our way
own pawn c
yes, that's it
of course critical literally following
two three moves will be completely clear
does the position have any
minimum chances for an advantage or black
pro calmly fights back up still sorry
that we can't get some hodgepodge
see so there was hope that it would play
option find rf and magnus well
really like like that's elmira
rightly rightly noted probably
still determined to play today
hold and then compete for victory in
match in rapid chess and blitz
yes I am, I'm trying to revive mine
unfortunately I don't have a computer yet
can read your chat message
I hope so, but I don’t understand that we
it's going to be a pretty long day today
up so im imagining for so long
will maxim his mooing yes absolutely not
I'm sure this will be a problem
let's do the following
exchanged for his seven hundred oda-kun would
one queen d2
I honestly don't remember why why
exactly how one would I start and whether it was
this is generally meaningful
the reason or she here may be you know
why because now it's like from 5 and
already since 3 did not fall already comic 3
does not hit, but what is now on the horse b1
black can pick up 22 before because of
weaknesses of the last horizontal, but not in the water
one intermediate already bumps into
first c6 and again a pawn under the gun
c2 that is, they do not say that y
whites like some kind of problem there but
at least it's black
hinder for the time being to revive this horse for 3 you
live maxim in this position wants to go
all the same, put the frieze again
And
chip seem 2 pieces on here and
it will be possible ondary h3 to
villains 8 pcs exchange play h3
play this best structurally well
what is white's next move say i would
I also want to make a window there
play conditional goulash theme 6 after h3
there is some and the rook would be black here to me
seems to be trying to keep
the voltage is quite long unfortunately on
t2 yes it’s impossible to take probably yes
you are probably right that the queen again
trying trying to put maxims come on
let's see if the magus finds some
a better antidote for it
because up can be conditional's elephant
5 vlady one heart 6
too primitive
or maybe just a6 again play me
I understand that the move is such a move
let's just say not the hardest date photo 6
again, well, take away from the queen, remember yes
owning a movie somehow there endure one
move play rest sd8 until white is
translate cognac he has din koonz this and
black, too, someone will have time for this contour
guru arrange get honest
big events await them though
I wonder what the first moment when Magnus
thought, that is, apparently all the same here
after the exchange after the exchange on and 8
the main line was not the move queen d2
who played maxim your body
graph
ilmira hushed up on trying
restore all the same chat work yes yes
you let's end communication with subscribers
true cycle it lasts for five minutes
and not bored
So what's going on in this
wonderful party 90 prison yes I am so
I understand that somewhere there in minutes
ten already we and
break let's get ready come on if we have
there is a chat there are some questions maybe
be try try about it
talk means you also have let's
russian ustream remind i am very happy
when Zhenya answers, she will also be very
happy to answer in france on
in Russian and in all languages ​​and time I
I guessed I can falcon
I'm terribly pleased with myself as if at 5 no
immediately sour had to be developed as
the same fools want to prevent white
calmly move the horse to the center
so the move is relatively
suggestive
and here is a very similar apparently setup to
tournament in the pit mind setup on stage on
tournament in india when if you remember
there are chess players and this is with his head up
looked at the ceiling here is the same thing
that is, since the game takes place on
stage, as I understand it, at the tables
chess player on one side of the scenes
the auditorium is located from the world
huge these screens on which
show the current position
Icarus himself what he found there for himself
interesting I don’t know my own or the party
or in the party denali same on the movements themselves
barn for the second semi-final there somehow
much slower
events unfold and and thousand 34
still depends andre same 4 played
movement is also very happy also spent
whites spent much more time
that is, apparently the approach of the bishop g4 was
preparation levon aronian and curious what
aronian and no at the board
that is, one made a move and continues
I don’t have to sit before Le Bon, but I don’t see here
alternatives to the move like 6 as soon as
he will appear at the board move serve 6 will
done to me as I understand it, but then
the question is when how white continue here and
know the supplies we found that's on
horse 5 seems to be possible to change in the center
on d3 go to her four i'm already like that
I wonder if they should then be white
first play elephant same 5 bind yes
and here to try to prove that black
some problems due to this bundle
just for the sake of
clearing the conscience let's check the stack 4
or just [ __ ] with your punches
it's just as long as golgi than for cars
put together what you need
somehow the elephant is all seriously very important
break down
name rain very understand the tip
this is one of the options
you can yawn so he is 5 firm gr5
just this option according to the Cossacks
weirdo umbra no i have possible
options just in this position show
well, yes, well, what are you, what tactics is class
it does not work for everyone because they found it
the horse is 5 black beat the cutter we are 5 then I
agree county personally spends queen at 605
in which, that is, I understand that the victim
there is such a thing, let's not
forget that there is even a move of the word before
3 no mat genuine dollars
protecting everything and everyone, that is, and if on with
you 2 5 6 Oleg would not agree two
or not good
I still consider myself a little stronger in
Oleg I don’t know maybe in practice
no game, well, I can tell it seems to me
one position in which there is some
compensation from another in which just
like to disagree no neither herself
proposed initially go 34 employees
a variant of this I wanted a stub from a
donate i work for daa content
after all, the king is the same 2 because even on
10 yes there will appear I draw an extra figure and
otherwise I'm not so sure that there is even a roller
and here is how right it is
I do not fully understand because
that yes there is a walker not 5 there is an elephant the same way
there is now I think what if I take
our 6 like this is not entirely logical
looks
it's impossible, well, that's how I would
I consider seriously or each all the same
in this position you need then already if on
e5 is worth giving, that is, potentially no
this move and everyone f6 school 5
worth well enough maybe i
I'm already alive, too, okay yes no everything
for some reason, elephant 6 doesn’t appeal to me
is either kanye 5 is sent the same 5 because
that one of these two
opportunities and now returned
Ivan Aronian at the board Bishop 6
really played right now I think
Chinese Tobacco will demonstrate to
skin with whom skin next move according to plan
but the ad is not just me it seems
to prove at least some white advantage here
if at all he is in this position maybe
be stanley the same despite 44
after all
plays very carefully
goes to the city
slope 5 toilet londa heels starts
itself
let's fill up the position enough
simple it seems to me it can be
a small period there is still me
I'm just looking for other alternatives
Bishop 5 already mentioned another move
which may not be very good
here but at the level of ideas, too, like
would be 4 to indicate that the elephant is here
a bit empty sometimes go knight c3 e2
and then somewhere either on f4 or
press f5
then try on the elephant to make 4 tm
peak tantalum their blow queen b3
either just black sooner or later
realize that the elephant will have to be returned
need 6 and 7 before i.e. most likely
most likely such an idea is possible, well, what
then leave denali not to think yes
seems to be very slow
this party unfolds
a couple of moves looking for played with maxim
against Magnus, which means I am in this position
I managed to revive my
computer and vk and view this position
in the database
Maksim Maklakov played in this position
elephant 5 how did you decide it was beautiful
miniature
see show like carson and
maxim and then we will have a break
so if we watch something
then after the break let's see
what happens at maxim and magnus
nothing happens bishop and 5 rooks
1-6 for now we just guessed our models
before guessing all the moves here we seem to be
decided that the queen needs to be played again, yes
that is, not that well, like one of
possible moves queen income 5
what else can I translate a lot for e3
here is the position of the model of the Vasya trilogy
thousands of these from b6 will improve, so
radial c3 also seems to me worth it
very clumsy
on the horse already at the exit and 8 I don’t know what
we want well suppose to suppose
the black row changes here for both
sides weak last therefore here
say option first c3 before black can
you can't take it easy on e3
queen because white gets first
checkmate post of the last horizontal
if you offer real 18 is still worth it
make planned photos of tights what then
I think black is also not particularly sad
that is, they beat you on e3 what comes
queen yes and here you know I suspect
that can not stand the nerves and
exchange already somewhere on b3 because
to play with such a terrible sodium horse
again a4 a6 black should sooner or
too late to play as I understand yes in general
it is not clear why black should be
worried positions too by feeling
full order, well, come on, little one
break until whom text
dear friends 1 hour is coming to an end
ether remind me give something 2
classical 2 last for semi-finals
classical game of the final tournament
grand tour in london while we have already
for the second year in a row no one can or can't
wants to win at least one game in the class
I remind everyone and remind the audience how
you want to say that we send with
chess player that 6 points 6 points for one
party when such a thing even happened
you gotta try you gotta try somehow
to distinguish themselves but still prefer
reliability and
and in the first round ended in
whose both parties in the past which country
finally i finally none
a successful game in the classics, we
and did not see it was incredible
number of results in rapid
but in the classics it is very, very reliable
I see something appeared a few
chat questions we are sure on them
we will answer after our small fiscal
goats we'll be back in the studio
abundance and I and not burge similar and
heaven over the grave viz achieve the pit
dylan de landa landing me and the world holster
your imam dad kuran and about him obroz
then there medley
[music]
tosato we have a hand on uncle and this time for
video poikanen road to his [ __ ] then
just he times it
valentina suck after commune natalia
knowing Peter the date of the reorganization
[music]
but
us while on us and the war i'm on myself beech i
it is clear that my beloved appeared there
battle
[music]
tatiana for memory 2 england
stop him comin' hope and believe
Cathedral of longing for Ivanovskaya they are your mother
Tina
strongly adamante on the device puts on
sock for the eyelid it sees
Arafat weather and but medline
because the wild grew constant so have found
her name is a new times
clink wars suede five tutaminis same
easy with your own there and
and Linton caught me [ __ ] minuses
hula medline senpai beko ce deans
diving in 8 already downloaded my wallet so
on the simple obsession
jacobi chaikin girls do flew into the house may
take to the people on the spaces of a
analysis of asset regulations and I'm wandering
Kitty
factor in apple
while u michon and your simpoll you're mounting in
edius war with their own la la
market itself money or 0 family and do you
believe how
import it is necessary cj go down again less
remote control catfish bay goats
smallville and ring things . downpour hryvnia
alder mast kindle van reported pro
supports cut and natural
of radio acne now eat up and pass
sum
[music]
by my surcharge peak
you will be a joy-con fireplace or on a computer
tango rhythm
aimed at number of people kulagin water
from the tank
ayhan darth vader to get from these mens
and in Samara because of grindal tobacco and again
this year
dark is not you yourself be an outcast work hard
which is peaceful but only dark her channel
Russian highways to Granberg photofast
amelie zlife
because the language itself
interview
[music]
I chose the same regulator to approach
[applause]
[music]
this is not a store and wrote marabou
I will sit rogen when the guy
the streets from the smeared would im jubilant such
[music]
spring often site legend
reissued hanging Dimitri
but don't poke your nose, I'm emily fun
now frond and synthesis soup from the face
companies
[music]
[applause]
welcome to our studio
I hope that Ivan is with you Lera
skripchenko evgeniya miroshnichenko probably
fun just saw saw a horse
so this is actually so alive
the reaction of the horse is also on the board here
remained
so let me remind you that in general chess
says well, and the college promised so
I keep my promise ilmir you said that
there were questions in the chat come on questions
answer was asked to talk about women's
grand prix and tournament in monaco yes i already
mentioned it yesterday that today
the first tour starts today tomorrow i
I don't know what day it is
today up to 1 round a stage of the grand prix in
Monaco
definitely one of the strongest tournaments and
too female in the world
I myself played it 3 years ago even 4
I know how hard it is to play the series
Grand Prix and
almost everyone plays this year
the world's leading chess players, but [ __ ] them
not involved in this series she is not
has recently taken part in
official tournaments from time to time
plays in the Bundesliga in the tournament without
rapid chess tournament
but even after changing the draw
World Cup she advocated for a very long time
for the change and but does not accept in part to
Grand Prix series apparently does not want
I don't know but you still
Of course, he continues his studies at Oxford
and who will win at this stage, well
a little bit how much you are very confident
won humpy cam on the same will play
And
from monaco there competition is very
serious again, it seems to me Giorgione
alexandra kosteniuk
nanojig no I will come to comment
this tournament literally immediately after
main sana 4 last tour i hope
that they will be very interesting decisive
four last then I so if you
interesting and women's chess join
and with me this time will be
comment Joseph Dorfman and we will
I don't know how to do it in English
I'm curious to see it with
gladly did but i will too
something there to comment so if
you are sick
[music]
definitely also matiz if you are sick
then get well please were not
need now before the heavy season we have winter
Yes, let's what else is there
more questions
that I have something to share here we go
incomes followed, that's probably the most
typical picture when the debut is already
played out and the exchange of moves so unhurried
once 51 chess players sit at the board
thinks they are sitting at the board at the moment
US
magnus carlsen and sits at another board
sits a day lying that let's get into position
the end of the look there is the most curious
it means maxim made the next move
while the most curious thing seems to me even
not so much the situation as it should be
for hours after all we didn't talk
today about control but we will remind you until 2 o'clock
10 minutes is given at the beginning of the game for
there is no more addition and here
so far so far the situation they are not
some kind of critical at maxim 1:20
but still here is a difference of 40 minutes
if this party continues if here
What is the minimum voltage
will be able to support magnus
at some point actually and the situation on
hours can be affected
the sim we talked to carson replies
so wait exchanged all the same on b3 yes
a b a b and h topic 64 then I played maxim
I still stand by my opinion
that this should not lead to some
White's advantage
to be honest, because it's still a horse
for 3
very strange what is meant here
well, that is, take it to d5, suppose up to
take and need 5 through d5 and what is here
jump then own again somewhere you can
and on b3 get to put the knight on c4
well, well, it's not entirely clear why
scientists, there may be some problems and
can maxim want to hold his horse
by 3 for now if black plays again
black, look black makes a window
i got you ideas there relatively speaking though the fetus
8 to pile on a pawn would be 3d max
Max
coupled with this played all sorts of money to
keep the pawn us three entrances getting younger
time it seems since he already took
plants c4
maybe even an oddity to cut something
there are probably three as well
you have to pay and you can start
owns Renault still can't do without
movement of one of the king's pawns
flank to get rid of floor threats
the last but in general that is, I do not see
why can't i see any clues
why blacks can have problems and
potentially if like I said
if black manages to support it
stress can be represented as words
seems stronger than the knight even for white
this communication plan is saved again
again a new couple you want when
while there is tension, here again I don't
everyone understands how this structure is for whites
resolve something in your favor because
that you obviously don't want to go c5 here yes
and obviously you don’t want to beat it, you need 5 thousand, that’s it
voltage i.e. black will
keep calm and after h3 already
you suspect you need to take some
considered not taken took but and so far
can't take on c4 and hall dress 3
which also seems to be lost
lost figure I tried to look at
water whales first run out again step 4
sf1 take her to d4 but must some
move to be with white he is in
here is Queen 5, for example, it threatened like
like the queen in 4 so stroked this
departure queens 5 white looks like everything
controls okay means and means and u
black
no better than this kind of equality game
it seems to me that in the second game we are there
mine, too, shied away from everything
met before we can
switch to the motion dyna part and
levon aronian and there he was played as
elmira says strange ring move 32
on the air it was not voiced as strange
let's see what happened in
this party after
already 5 why ding decided on a horse 2 before in
this party reminded me of this escort before
break is maxim milk in one of
it seems to me some kind of rapid tournaments
chess played against the sanji component
with a low rating, I think so
there is still see what can
give character fight and uk drawing auto
same 5 saloon have seven been played
clerk
already and queen b3 forever once it's already
hard and pullmans but because what u
them there happened there black by we
handed out all the pieces up through the aisle
money decided all the same and what is
changing the structure of the sun require c
still on the hand of black and therefore went
the horse is barely in this position yes he is right here o
than I said to prevent and
exchange on on c3 and secondly whether the knight
Tallinn is 3 or somewhere on me at 4
can be chosen and it turned out that the horse
barely knight c6 understandable so logical
development of pieces and the bishop went to the same 5 and
black answers live 8 and 8 i.e.
visible idea colder 8 and 8 prevent
lunge of the knight on e5, let's say y is the case of the bishop and
why whites might think about how
her 5 again somehow either f4
keep it away well bye u
actually nothing threatens the knight on e5
already some options with taking on 6
if black changes then queen b3
and I'm here maybe one more moment
I don't know any move here
black we'll make it up to the rook
let's say again if you hold the horse on and
5 immediately then we miss her walker 4
here is one possible option
take on and lice personally and
play 4 now i don't think it is
there is somehow especially good for whites in this
editions, but conceptually there are such
there are also such games we exchange char
support the outdoor knight on e5
gourami where is g3 here I am
I suspect that after six dream when with
problem as in that position it seems to me
that black here you are, do you think you
that such a strategic
idea of ​​black layer 4 you won't be beaten on
petre i still try to install
elephant on and 4 depends on let's say on
that's but you're on the fabric at 4 to
or get along separate invented how
specifically continue by manocare position
you don’t have anything, well, that is, we don’t know
what move did she love to go to get away
one seems to me that a little well, how
to say not specifically yes that is understandable
yes venice open line here i am she alone
while doing nothing on the feel of now
some move of the knight and 2 to see either
she is 3 on f5 or on f4 there with
potential son-in-law on the same 6 let's say walker
not at 4 but even nominally a threat to it
still creates as if in 3 candida 5 then
there is scrap byd f6 combine again if
with the queen, black beats then maybe yours
servant move 4 is just right for
existence as quickly before the first
class
did I like the image of magnus and when he
was wearing glasses and with a hairstyle a la love
chamber Zhenya will also be able to answer
this question is very remember you know me
it seems so
personal choice of each person I sometimes
they always notice in fact
changes, strange as it may seem
if magna advice enjoyed enjoyed
labor please yes why not and
and again already always in front of me
it seems that this is a change of image
most likely commented here and
media on
social media again makes it possible
speak not only important but magnussen but
also chess is somehow
in a roundabout way
why not here is such a question or the world
questions about women's chess, what do you think
why such a huge purchase between
men and women in chess to me
seems like it's been mentioned already
physical activity is very high
chess
it seems to me that a lot and
physiological differences and again
play a chess tournament that lasts
at least nine days or even two weeks
all the same, it’s not so simple, for example, I’m in my
a lot of time and still devote
a lot of physical time
training lately I've been running from 10
up to 15 kilometers there two or three times a
a week is easy
I think you should
how to mention that chess is
sport
Magnus again too much time
gives his out of training and everything
leading chess players again with this
engaged in me seems such a load as well
not maintained by the female body
so just some certain
I think we can go the distance
on the same level that's the end
tournaments, I notice that I am also very
I'm very tired mentally, too, not just
when you're not sleeping
even the participants in this tournament complain
the fact that you can’t sleep and the flight
these live members complain all the time
curious but also a commentator
complain
so it seems to me that actually
the gap in modern chess is no longer the same
big [ __ ] again involved they're in
tournaments showed that she is capable of them
win the leading men's tournaments but
it's not that easy to do anyway
support such a
stability like magnus carlsson
I'm getting out Magnus this is again this is weird
so you know how to navigate
on the magus because he is even in men's
ad template is absolutely unique
No, I don't think that's quite right.
will be here especially in connection with his
I also don’t know physical preparation and for
how long are such
sports, it seems to me sometimes at the training camp
more than chess should, again, this
doesn't mean it has to be
what should be a model for everyone yes then
it's still very individual
someone more sporty someone less
sports, I don’t know maxims for example
he is doing some kind of physical
yes maxim
running a lot lately
again this year did not get to
so little time between
tournaments, but he often sits in
I saw Hikaru Nakamura at the gym
fabiano is constantly sitting in the gym
caruana he generally has a certain physical
preparation and he has his own coach who
creates a specific program for it
and given the specifics, again, the shahman then
there are glasses on the chest they are engaged in no
disappears already answering bets on questions
decide what the male body delays
such load 8 minutes chess at no
doing some kind of
sports, he withstands these loads more easily
I saw how
it's not easy if you don't support
physical form for example I was very
difficult to withstand long distances and
so I started very
run a lot and, in principle, now it’s
I hope it succeeds
run a half marathon in paris
I'm just smaller now and played well
that let's get back to the fingers
especially until there is nothing to return big
there are no changes, that is, maxim spends
more and more time and it seems yes
after h7 h6 cd first beta 5 was played
cavalry 4 that is, as I said in
white apparently rested in this structure
hard hard something smarter
come up with what to take and on d5 after which
I think we are in this position
approximately discussed what is unlikely here
does black have any problems at all
it may be necessary not to substitute there under
conditionally kanye 3 or water and 5 all of a sudden
it didn’t turn out that we were losing our figure, although even
it seems to be impossible yes it always is
move through d7 and here it is probably already possible
talk about that's how black then
to play for the advantage of this
play with tension
minimal at least allowing
the enemy to make a mistake because well
say some move al-alla dyad 8
who is quite human
cultural given most likely white
knight e3 will be exchanged for f5 and
semi-final while the party entered the logres to
once it ends in a draw pretty quickly
that is, can blacks afford
let's say play until the bishop is 6 or something
move the queen to not give
exchange a couple of minor pieces, yes, that's it
and the thing is so strange to me there is no
comfortable way here save figurines
maybe the whole b5 oddly enough here
they again all the same due pawn sacrifice
is it possible necessarily b3
well, we haven't played h3 yet, oh well
look at through would sing somehow to me
it seems more specific or something
there is also an attack on b3 immediate
rook e5 looks like we can just take
Yes, I didn’t think about the horse 505
I can retreat with the queen, it seems to me 6
and shox would one give then x after taking on
f5 well, you're still superfluous
pawn with minor pieces preserved
this is just an option
if black tries to play better 6
kanye 5 here pick up on b3
here it seems to me dobby white without haste
remain but after taking a knife there 6
conditional here probably for higher chances y
whites to jump off, although I will also give somehow
to remain without a pawn it is not clear why
we already see that potentially thefts
black can try a little on this
stance maintain play to win
he is justice for us aka 6
probably don't need to mess around
need to go to her 5 can somehow the
first c3 while play and try it
lead to someone
ending in general high expectations that
it will outgrow what is sharp honestly
saying no yes well and second hope
dressing clear old I already switch
from the ice to the second batch come on yeah too
let's see where the Aronian movement is there
a little here is a series of moves incomprehensible to me
occurs after white rook 8 has taken on
already 6 here to discuss played water c1 and whether
he walks ferris conversation you see he
still took on the same part what after
get along 1
still had as immediate owner
one probably an elephant not 4 was yes well what am I
I wanted to point out that this is not very logical
looks like take she same 6 without any
immediate continuation something must
it would be in this position kuni 5 like
we see it's kind of just a lining, yes, but
that's usually how that's the course of the fight you
you hit on the same 6 to do something very
specifically because after the exchange and
such an insinuating move by the owner one
blacks no longer have to care about
horses 6 they can safely play here
ferris to 7 untie
because the capture on f6 is no longer
leads to muscle deterioration
black is more likely to improve because
if you take on f6
black background gets opportunity king
g7 playing rooks h8 is generally easy
preponderance will stand that is until it
everything looks very decent for ryan and
by the way, you wanted to beat 4 there
maybe it's in this position already
soon she will be ripe for
Blacks got ideas to take she woman
on 0 6 still needed not on the next move but
in general, yes, in general, already some motives
appear moreover kanye 4 flashes
Why do I feel gradually comfortable
the position may be yes, here we are
it is curious that in both games we have
white much more time spent
and it seems that both here and there the blacks have complete
comfort run even played on
preponderance
that is, this is the situation that
said when white was in such a match from
two batches on white under a certain
pressure that you kind of need to
for all yes for all that's the law you must
fight for the upper hand
and you do not want an advantage in the wrong place you
keep going like this
make some move and then found out
that actually is no longer someone's wrong
easy to do and not easy
switch to actually then to
fight for a draw what you already understood
somewhere here I think that money was needed
not just Christ is also made not there he is
not right, well, well, if that's white
let's say all the whites realized everything and now
how now how now actually
culturally do nothing now again
I feel like it makes no sense
the feeling that if you skip cognac
it can get really sad there
be on f6 really beat beat
walk so he is 3 then he he will idle
acquired pretty where he goes on their not
that's me and they wanted to I wanted to press
either hold the villain 4 that mineral as
the translation salon again elephant big
villain 4th have a pawn would be lost
it seems to me here to walk back and or out
them 1 up if you don't want to
if turn over and delivery yes but here
you wanna spit attack the run
g7 should play that steal 2 useful
yes, well, then something needs to be thought about 6
vladimy needs to solve the issue with black
because is it necessary to move with one rook
our 8 2 on and 8 or somehow two tacs e in
in general
really feeling that if someone
play for an advantage here and color the black one
same switch fight for the equation
grin how right you are a dream and lice are their dream
4 I don’t want to find it, he even thought
f4 duck she has four black jumps you
you can probably change one pair of horses
typikon show horse and 5 servants 5
well, even it looks nicer for blacks
positions in addition black can be
may not rush to jump on and show 4
control the field and 5 don't care
play elephant until 6 wait and on elephants 4
didn't you mention kuni four at once
here loading all the same it seems to me but
right here until these disks
it turns out combi g4 and g4 have long forgotten about
this idea and the knight on f3 hangs, and if
play knight g3 write there like f4
drainpipes just don't have that is either
finished three but then they don't understand how
answer find she has four either
already have to rot yes something alone
movement somehow not very successful peppers
he played everyone, maybe he didn’t either
had a good sleep of radiation on cardboard and all who
although 5 commentators are also in the fifth
fine don't know please give me
since only fat from yes i will be back
We'll see
and such a pause we are on the air remind that
not the time said dreams are not the kind you know but
you keep talking I won't
keep talking all the emphasis on you
were on the screen and all so to speak
The audience was frozen in anticipation
read this question and you solved it
read about myself I you need to delve into
no it is not necessary to delve into yes
so if i keep talking i'll do it again
I will continue to talk about chess that I
understand what you've just been done
statement that I have such a question even
no triptych questions so I had to
read all
and the happiness of last week's question
South Korean game master in a year and one
of the most titled players in the world
Sedolya announced his retirement
made a dramatic announcement
how did artificial intelligence start playing
in a year I realized that I would not even be the best
if I lead the rating due to the insane
efforts and now there is an essence that is not
defeat elmira evgeniy can we wait
what is similar in chess
also appear, it seems to me that this is already
chess players will not play demanding
change seems artificial to me
intelligence has reached such heights after all in
chess what
we're not even worth talking about this
situations about how artificial
intelligence helps now chess player
yet again
analyze positions search maybe
some form of absolute
beauty and thought all the same absolutely
truth and truth of the same who that me
it seems that harmony in chess is very
what matters is this absolute truth
Anna and causes it all the same very
shows the answer or peace of this question
shows what kind of eyes she has
looks at the world because it seems to me
that computers play extremely
very ugly but extremely rare
ugly all these computer
codes it's of course it's it's very
hard to endure it seems to me again in
chess is still so much creativity despite
for the presence of computer
programs, we manage to monitor this and
there are a lot of interesting ideas in tournaments
that's why it doesn't seem to me that a chess player
let's just say let's get a little familiar with
this topic just yesterday I read and so
just a small advertisement at the same time
dad implicitly what's on the channel in the telegram
a motley garden that leads
beautiful I don't know first of all
comrade probably and fine poker
commentator Ilya Gorodetsky
channel dedicated to all kinds
sports poker and so on event
and just yesterday he described that
there happened and in his opinion me
it seems not only to Ivanovich as a whole
the general human opinion that it is simple and
South Korean
the go player got a little excited because
that a long time ago a long time ago a car
faster than a person moves on the ground
it didn't cancel the running competitions yes
beat chess players for a long time
chess program anyway we play
5 of the world and so on and respectively in
principle and gof as a sport could well
it's okay to develop
the computer began to play stronger than a person
we have
ladies and gentlemen cook random
Achieve a draw yes in your logr's game
And
against entered Lavrov and Magnus
carlsen, that is, it’s just left here
look at technology
general exchange let me come back
by the time when still really what
then the semantic load in these moves was
after ring 4 - answered and 6 rooks 5-7
d5 and here Magnus played the water live
after which yes here followed yes and a
another on and a friend's knives never
especially yes if white even
trying to somehow defend it is necessary to move 5
marten 3
I suspect it might be bad for them.
ends but like this
funny options to all f6 that owners
36 and 6 yes u should 2 hangs at white fest
respectively Ambassador grandfathers 8 white
they take on e6 the exchange is replenished there on d2
followed but we'll see later
now we have a lodey ending with an equal
the number of pawns that's right besides
hackneyed expression pierced nothing special
so there is nothing to say about this
a party that is very confident is very
confidently Magnus beat off the move more or less
anyone could do your 5 has
the right to exist that king h7
king h6 neither side here porridge on
does not win
we actually wait, as I understand how long
there requirements or 30 or 40 moves
cannot be offered at night yes probably 40
moves
as soon as the party continues in
official tournaments species we have 32 year
I don't remember life on an orchid
organizer's discretion how many
What are the restrictions for the organizers?
grand clean while answer small
the question I mentioned was that I was playing with
habu
in chess or all gi you know both
other on about the parties which I
told we played with him of course
chess and
he plays very well and again
Lots of great ideas but worth it
expect from such a brilliant player
in shock and
and he loves chess very much
chess from time to time but he again
does not allow his schedule to participate in
chess tournaments here it is look at
blackboard
French trick played rook a7 a8
maximum hope for king 6 here I am
kashtak knot yes it is clear that checkmate in 1 move
the world champion will not blunder, but nevertheless
well, white has an extra pawn
continues zhenya that's how you think
such tournaments
maybe change the party system
so that there are no permanent draws
classic pull through we try
like to change the system we give 6 points
for the victory what do you think I'm still standing
don't seem to need at all you know not
I need to touch the chess just about I don’t
really like this idea
what let's change so let's change
everyone that is exactly right but again
so I'm telling you exactly right now
meaning my personal opinion
definitely need to play for someone
with the elimination
Might be worth a try here
a system that for some reason does not
chess was used but at least
I don't know much about tournaments
on such a system on such a system in
chess but it is actively used in
billiards it is used in e-sports
that's the so-called and sleep until you
using double like it will before was
Lee the cutest is called in English
such a double elimination how would you wait
how you lost you fall into the bottom
part of the grid so to speak and anyway
you can go back to the end
that is, this is the only one like
the only argument against knockout
system what can be matches Sean
one stupid mistake and you
dropping out of the tournament, that's what it looks like
swept aside after we give
losers as a second chance to pass by
the bottom of the grid and then you can
consider just a match between two
players as a single sports
event and don't get upset if yes here
on the first day we got it
short draw with white well then we have
will be the second day we will have case 11
there we have a tie-break yes that is it
perceive everything as one event but
let's say like a football match which
passes up to some ridiculous
themselves in the middle of the field but at the end then
ends with extra time
hype or post-match series
penalties that everyone is watching with burning
eyes
I can easily make a draw after
major spinal scheduled for tomorrow
extra time and kick well a revolver
there will be a penalty if they are in all
disciplines will finish with an equal score yes
if corners the total score in the match will be
equal it could rather be yes wow
are there any super short ones like this
Break yes 'til yes here's the mighty king
h5 then of course the correct income
was king h7 more pawns our husband was 6
pawns of ours to put a maximum of h4 water on
2 no refuses how to pick up but
the most technical move rook b2 to
to exchange all that is left for
utensils on the board as we have already seen to
example of a tournament in india headquarters is possible
put the king of the fat boy in the chessboard
parties
the voltage was high so here and there
king e3 could go on
fight killed the old king closer to
center
very supportive in chat
interesting ideas
lower end like what can be to you
the organizers will listen, there will be tournaments
with this format is likely to be
popular I don't know
look add showmanship up to for
letters rogue this is for those who do not know
how does this actually happen
it's all the so-called bottom half
grids where everything is added gradually
who lost at least one match and the winner
this lower half of the grid plays
the final match is just in poker too
there is a similar system, but
more, as it were, systematically connected with the Riga
yes after the first exit from the tournament
they give you, for example, the second time
to participate in the tournament but with
final knockout to give
just an opportunity for participants to
fight for victory even in this case
rode a city firefighter with dirty money a
yet because this is such a junction so we'll be back
probably to the only party that
continues with us until
to be honest, it's not even clear here we are
could analyze what
happened at Maxim with Magnus
again, it might be interesting
peek at the interview in english
channel then by the way if we have mine
just a minute i might be back anyway
strange to the first batch between carson
I ate your coffins I yesterday because
what was revealed in the interview
interesting moments because the players
made the right moves with the wrong ones
oddly enough justification yes you're not all
seen at the board but that's not intuition
failed and the party turned out to be the highest
the quality of one's moving which took on
and here is one movement that happened but
really too annoying
looked like this
the knight's jump to e4, so he still took
on f6 ferris played d3 and rook and 4 play
ramming
she finished
I am 2 8 I showed in this probably the idea yes
while pick up the line while pick up the line and
and then we'll see which repetition gave
day in 4k i don't think blacks want
I'm not asking you to repeat blackly
the advantage is already well, or at least they
fighting over moving water f4 given
you probably have the right to go to the water at four
she is not caught there in some way and presses
on a pawn t yes well white to this machine with
I'll share it with pleasure
pleasure will go to her e2 back then
White already has no reason not to repeat
position and black probably has
this will be the party in which its on
holds first class win
interesting point I think so
the computer evaluates this in favor of black
for a number of facts, after all, an elephant
against a horse yes, well, somehow mad
the structure should not even be more compact
play very carefully
you know how and maybe knight c3
still come back yes I understand that
let's acknowledge it a little
psychological defeat so wait a
finally e3 here you know what's going on
at the end of 3 here can be seen as
no strange water exchange 4
could it be
on the stock exchange 4, well, that is, black is like
minimum is perpetual check
the fact that there is a queen h3 on the king h1
king h2
even more unfortunate for the king of the same seba
rook on the water sa8 get run around but here
if black has more than perpetual check i
I don’t understand yet, that is, you can give shox
h3
king same one out here try
look for a move yes well here unfortunately on
whom g7 is the backdrop of hype
and maybe not necessarily Cooney 50
. none yes by the way she has one too
enough then that no sesame water
that's why
and if they donate you all the same
use tip
played kuni 2 end 3 remember well
said but why not beat the sun 3
i.e. return to this position on ps3
beat
when you need somewhere to fight
until his unfortunately position is going nowhere
only no horse already two horses 3
I would like to somehow attack the pawn
d5 rather well, maybe by the way, as well as
very like it's not nasty to go horses
one knight is yours then there is a rook and
1 of 3
trying to trade so sorry here
here white suggests something ali
pancakes one and one on black do not beat
it's just that problems don't hit black
black it might be ip65
already walking in this position yes it is possible and
to problems to play for what not at all
a simple problem of lying dyne it must be said
very nasty positions they just
came to them now he is literally here
some very simple simple moves
that is, black is not something that they did
something out of the ordinary come on
finally try the fare like this
market he's demanding not days not quite
I understand what White's next move might be
be queen retreat
with the threat still on and 4 take let's say through
d1 not that i was terribly happy about it
move
well then the big question is whether blacks want
anyway quality donate what but
can theoretically be considered
some thin guys 5 or you can just
retreat inflict them also does not arise
as if doubt black is very comfortable
opposition before the elephant must 6 retreats
king is 7 and already ready there somehow
activities at the tip wait through
five after 18 yashka always want specifically
check to her 4d and again but don't want to
they want to repay them for what not 4 to reach
up to 4 here sit up to 5 on f how it goes
this option
you can pass, that is, you mean
that rook move 8 can't be done no I don't
I'm sure thousands of people ran if
I'll get some 5 by 3 5 black maybe
be not this by the way, even if she herself
put of course is not yet entirely clear
how
just 5 systems are not for me at all
like somewhere here there is some
line here kanye 5 give on be four
five icons d3 win back nazi 1 here
I'm afraid to transfer blacks to treat and not
will say frieze
somewhere on 411 changed yes that is from
black lavender black not much risk
of the divine she is worth these
this position is somehow yes hardly black
Husband Reef Takes Big Risks 5 Go To The Whole
but it is hardly a question, but with the weight of black
so after com same 3
listened to day 8 it turns out because of here
this tactic may not work, I don't
know why pants slave
as if again in even in such a position
retains a lot of tactical ideas
let's accept rooks 8 knights 4d and festa
four computers caught up laughing at this
how do you think about
artificial intelligence what to laugh
uchur traits should beat the horse and henceforth not
laugh so that no one would take away
her 4 walked in ephesus then 4 you see how we
operate
human such concepts alon you
probably collected data 4 1 6 4 and
I looked at us black to us
showed that now they have changed a little
times and
Yes, this is so typical for chess players
joke about how much
chess players play materialistically
programs actually suspect that
will be just in what now in what
component, the chess
programs in particular with the advent
neural networks with the advent of alpha zero what
just such long long current
development initiative before after sacrifice
materials if you look at the parties here
this thing here
neural networks up to often the same
motive you're a victim of material or a pawn
or sometimes pieces for a couple of pawns and
very long such a long playing attack
which resembles to 1 human
intuitive
but it seems to me that I managed to make all
grieved burns us decision without making
solutions thanks to retrograde analyzes
not to myself that I at one time they are many
talked to developers
at that time it was a type of chun
I just told them how they
sought such positional sacrifices and
how they tried to change the algorithm
decision making chess programs what
now let's see Levon Aronian's reactions
because up to rook a and 8 looked
attractive until now
as the world said that she would take on e4
accordingly, it may be necessary
I know how to walk
then it's very hard to understand
it's hard to justify rook 4 because
Yes, it's probably not too late to retreat on and off
and say let's play this position then
not really
wait, maybe there's something in it
logic I wanted to say that then they say
one could own everything at once play on
water and all at once could be white
played not even three on and four with an idea
so wait for the elephant to 6 just no well
let's say if this horse is somehow
ask at 4 yes there say move through
b6 maybe he goes for same 2 then
moves to e3
some kind of logic here
they say after you own not recon the same trilogy
sem stuck skate stuck on the same 3 and
and again black somehow I don't care
say even this position seems to have
black is just nicer bishop up to 6 the same
today and university
I decided to check what the computer thinks and
a position that seems to me very difficult and
not a human decision at all
position he walks the water and 8 after the horse
3 weasels 4d and yet it goes after
first all four he offers this
point of view interesting under screen g6
he appears to 6 judges on the t-55 and
knight d4 and knight 4 needs a sacrifice
as some I even you think in
this moment when heart 4 we played i
even considered some version but I
it was hard to believe that it works yes
another 1 to 5 packs we have four more than 4 water
3 country out as everyone will appreciate
Black's position is a little better a little better
there up to a dozen would not be curious at 30
let's say it's not a supercomputer
but I was very interested
understand what he thinks about it
answer we said just such
positional victims transparent initiatives
blacks have a long-term initiative
moves on 3 queens 7 him 1 of 2
Well, you see, maybe tactical
rebutted then there is entrance possession 8
how then the opposite is not refuted
because here is no idea from month 4 mine
the idea wanted to pick up on 4 5 6 4 to 5
but look here
and honesty is human magic a and 8
why say so quickly and easily
is a purely human point
view of the most let's say the fastest
move in position yes i.e. we want
come true watering want to spend no
pace and it seems that we have
tactical clothing and
it looks like he did not dare to do it
retreats to
and 7 follows from my point of view like this
mysterious photo 23
because the bishop on b4 is like himself
would like to have to go 6 but apparently the logic is in
to walk, owning the dyna, change the fret
this is what grandfather wears for a day and two
three now on the elephant to 6, as I understand it
what follows
one of the villains will go to e1 and try
change heavy pieces it looks like
after all
it was such a real game of advantage
related case I have a question who
came up with this control
how the organizers came to this
such time control in this tournament
grand astor series
then we'll have to ask the organizers
we were actually told when
first classic crunchies tournament
tour of croatia passed i will
commented with the doctor on the shoulder and yes
then they said it was a little
surprisingly it turned out to be very
interesting and in a different way it is necessary, as it were
allocate time until it seems that
there is a lot of time, this habit is what
up to 40 care what will be added and mentioned
I have repeatedly played this same party
carson mamedyarov where not by the thirtieth
go both spent there so hardest
there was a party that both spent almost everything
time played time trouble but at the same time played
very cool who watering who came up with
control, to be honest, was not asked
this question is enough and spectacular me
seems to depend already shoot me
seems like time control
at least for a minute, and for people at least three
hours before all the same first
what happens on the board is important, of course, but
I think it's important to keep
color stage in a batch
any form again for me
perfect mind control without adding
not in early stages
up to 40 care, that is, again, save
network musical stage because all the same
it is worth encouraging the players who play
quickly sometime maybe some stage
school desk superficial but they spend
less time of their rivals
color and add time after 40
moves to avoid these a few
sometimes a cruel situation where I'm not alone
spent the other side than to avoid
cruel situation is to realize
advantage just do not drive there what you
the flag is not for me it seems that it is very
important but here is to keep the network musical
stage add time to 40 pics me
seems very interesting but not clear
why is it so now I'm so just
case make a reservation that yes it is a joke
this act is not quite so worded in
in general, I don’t understand why feel sorry for the slow-witted
perfect was still the final control
when there was no addition but no
did you have time to protect yours
problems on the other side and at the time
we also postponed the parties again
there was time for reflection
a lot and
some kind of golden mean
the specifics of Hawaii should be taken into account
and those chess players who like to think
And
just wait, it turns out that is
a chess player prepares for an hour for five hours
before the party then them a lot of time
because he still has an addition but this is not
works in the 21st century must be accelerated later
accelerate i really really
like the idea to leave that's a factor
time pressure of the date so as not to be added before
at some point there was no addition to
30 seconds probably what we'll say here
there is an hour and a half or something
the amount of time here is 40 moves and it takes
make without any additives and probably
all the same, yes, if you are so serious, then you
rights so that well, should not be played by
time position with an extra rook in the data
relatively speaking, to avoid here
these were at the highest level
these ugly moment remains not
understands the meaning yes that is some
addition there but may be nepal minutes
minimal let's say yes that's it to
realize an absolutely winning position
five seconds is enough for him not to
accumulate time i.e. do not repeat
position and don't use it on
pondering some supplement sometimes well
most likely this is very
again here is an elegant control solution
and chess and immediately give out everything all the time
210 no I lead without adding time to 40
before it's there somehow your 15 minutes
15 plus 10 let's see what happened
the ability to just go to the toilet
let's say to survive the cement fever face
and these cold in yours or less often and
think a little so what happened to us
see the following after the logs and scheme 23
plays yes and there already mentioned the elephant up to 6
owning one might also look like something
it all slows down a bit
the white house somehow managed not to feel
adjust the interaction of figures too 3 in
water and one villain 8 just looks like
the villain has time for the white white date
that is, he hardly let everyone influence the prize
rook and took away rook and 1 is there
some problems here it could be
the minimum can still be arranged
some trouble yes but wait a minute
exodus heart 7 say
while attacked by the same 3 dans on out of it
cannot be taken because in between
we beat on the same 3 with a check, respectively
need to play wheel or king same 2 yes us
bull roles given then black change
Kunyi 1 and why tasks are up to everyone
fart and on b6 attack two pawns
king we go to the slag and decided to commission i
I suspect it's right
still maybe not on f2 king
leave him for life is a question well
go to this position and after the queen would 6
I don't quite understand what this is
how will it be assessed
that I'll call what if we're in the horse
endgame let's go black then at the expense
the activity of the king will be a good chance
dismount say king e3
knight e6 yes somehow there knight up to 3
although things may not go anywhere.
we organized not yesterday a very camera by
Traditions without haste go into writing
there as well develops to be and
develop gave out decided to remind that
there is also a second open line
exchanged for yadi finds the king
life will be some attempt to deliver
rook our 8 see to fully complete
probably black needs mobilization of forces
will the horse translate here I am now
I understand that start-ups will tell everyone
some white move some college 2
Like
rook h8 suppose and a maneuver appears
horse to 8 and 6 to 4 if of course the horse
run to the fields a6 already there much
more unpleasant they were
looks very interesting and I think
so the lemon ones are preserved the same elephant
do not drink on the knife 3 that our horses press
forest you do nothing well
performs some significant function
so they need three nothing special to do and
it is not clear where this means one of those
positions I think
when one side here is worse structures
it is necessary because here is the advantage in
chess, if there is any discussion at all
dynamic factor is static and
that's when I have worse dynamics
this is how it is described i have
Lovely brim up for curly them not
managed to put it here here
take this horse in your hand with the same 3 and say
here's where to put it at least so that it
stood perfectly and in fact any
fields are found some flaws
probably poorly resisted yes there but even before
live on c5 then he away from
kingside, then maybe some
problems be meant white
apparently here you write unsuccessfully, but also
arrangement was arranged after
it's hard to find good figures
Parking up to the veins he acquired some
function perform us cover
some fields of the new as a whole as a whole
we must agree that Aronian is enough
that's quite unpleasant once set and
Dean will probably still have to
be precise before you succeed
fight back if you manage to conquer
got excited about the movement 34 where of course
interesting, but it seems to me that
case again if you take take
responsibility for oneself is just
the root cause was a move that did nothing
I liked the move of the horses, well, at least
combination of hodovka not 2 if he is 5
which Genle did not play it
it looks like it should be recognized
unfortunate well what's going on 2
second semi-final second game of the second
semifinal let me remind you that you ate the coffin and
magnus carson classic parts
both ended nothing here yet
as long as the fight goes on maybe
district will be able to win the first victory in
classics in history
these distance and tension we
let's take a short break
us here floor gibson fluid so it's time
what to do for a cup of coffee at noon
probably dream of coffee now we will organize
yes, we'll be back in ten minutes, we'll continue
follow the developments in the party
denali same her and
early she may have time to show that
before
from the first guys like carson came
[music]
and you mom about
our war is impossible for a second
of on be they son of his
really a lot of house problems
boris sympho black
[music]
in this from whose a i run and ubisoft and how
politics
orders.
are you gonna make a spring and either she
and verbatim
avis falling stories analytics premium
spoiled thrunite
much later want to give sphere jolie tags
on the
amrita to her water itself or or spiritual
yard
[music]
here's the trouble stroller cam yourself
thread hatches for cosmonaut sergeev
or another subscriber
and I basically eat a lot of james
wavy foil to whom the piping is okay and
not
england tuesday or other site
ive 8 lego sumo no stories .
my bullets night sochi
[music]
clouds
find and
[music]
remember
you
having a home
[music]
oh dear comic revealed
choosing
I
[music]
1 you save the steps
repeat .
I am little today
while I think
two will
11 off the stone for there dollar
with awards
she is one
[music]
she formula 1 album
and from the variations
rin gave coal
[music]
we dryly counted ndis
its module to the more do
nissan universe has deformation come on without
share dogma choosing a battle
solder and market then people
[music]
in the history of oh sites of sochi world and
compact x3
killed
[music]
she
mum
baby im
[music]
smooth
here from 2010 1
pluses i pass to give mah
then and
andre moreau
yes visitors
mina fiber moscow on cam only
passed
[music]
but
and here
[music]
on the
none
[music]
so back to the studio of the world temporarily
can't talk break worked up
managed to have a bite trying
condemn what you managed to snatch
during a break with our chess players
there is no break the party goes on
still 40 minutes difference on the clock
Levon still has a better position
aronian ivan grivel horse on and 6 and
Yes, let's now show you where it is
there was a horse and 6 and I wanted more
mention overheard me from comments
English studio what something like this
but the position is being evaluated what is to come
quite a long defense on here they are
discussed but I think we are too
discussed what if
black do not leave as we know yes at
with the help of the computer, black could still
knight g3 answered rook e-8 and don't retreat
and 4
then it would be possible
assume that this is a direct attack
until black finishes the game like this
now it looks like this
long-term advantage is on the side of the Aronians
but you won't be able to win the game quickly with
one side up white sort of like
established where minimal coordination yes
and on the other hand, this is what we discussed
also absolutely wording sounded in
English studio that it is not clear what
must make black to eat too
must make white to completely
equalize yes, that is, it defends like
maybe defend those squares on f4 as
then translate these horses but here's a direct
ways to the equation just about what you want
white do what then say what
I'm not afraid of anything, maybe this horse is in
hour last move ends 3 went to d2
maybe it translates like this
the knight is transferred to e3 in order to
put pressure on the pawn d5 what to find out for him
that on f3 he had nothing to do
especially who the other side who
will keep the field h21 and you follow
words h1 i live h1 and anyway
let's say so here I am h1 anyway on
agenda because blacks have
one of the potential threats is
play for h8 where such a g5 attack
real estate h3 to finish already sitting
to give, that is, some kind of service 8-6
permutation means to send h8 at the very
I don't really understand how one
going to react that's say rook
h1 knight g5 and maybe like this
position arise cony fadina i'm trying
understand you can take our you me today
strokes same 4
having to forced to walk owners
3 here is the elephant 31 of the horses, let's say
knight knight ev1 beats g3
I'm trying to convince myself that it's not necessary
give two checks
our exercise 2 can be and should be well
suppose at 5 yes, well, here are some
such positions yes because all the same two
we cover the horse quite reliably there
no, I yawned clothes for a second so
what is not worth it at e3, yes, but to 4
didn't go it's not clear here I'm completely
I'm sure black is up to something 3
queens 55 keep while pawn at 6
rook
training rains may be queen h3
elodei vasya in three checks shorter than one
water and 8 may be needed for hosts 3 to
that is, again, the days seem to be white
lose immediately if Bela is not about the game
right away they may not lose at all
say some ending with a rook
against two horses but she will be very
clear
when we walked these wanted to save and
threat
then you need to return to our 80 h 1 he
same 5 horses 1 out of 5 great-grandfather they will take
kunya 4 can put ideas in 5 well
then apparently he is 3q g3 I suspect not
they will change black in general, that's something
something like this might happen
potentially continuation of the party until
Still Aronian while initiative
absolutely right
and dan will have to be so careful
fight back carefully
given as soon as we have a calm here
some kind of Levon for an hour and a half
in any case yes you can definitely afford
think let's do this
promised let's look at the first
semi-final game between Carson and your
kilogram I'm here on the board literally
wanted to show some options
yesterday's party that transpired during
during the press conference
after all, the chess players saw in the meantime
u call you many of you played yeah
that's as soon as I manage to show yes
now let's have us shown in
studio yes so come back like this
small flashback to the first game
semi-finals yes that's absolutely correct
graphics what is classic and first batch
this was the critical moment
there were many critical moments we
we will not, I think, discuss the debut again
it's clubs and deep this idea yeah that's
after the sun move 5 cavalry 5 max
played queen 2
water up to 8 and did not see x 24 which is a little bit
mysterious because if whites don't
I want 4 large tonic not of course bad
they are just bad so not everyone understands
what he watched and now after c4 it turns out
to colors correctly rook and d2
allows for the same repetition
which happened party
your leg not seeing us at last cheats on
instead of rook move food 2 no here is the maxim
just after the move of the knight 4 he said that he
was going to go c3 that doesn't work
option which will be which we
discussed with you mine step sp3
jb thrill king dressed one layer 4
White would have 8 king a4 here
actually won position
but after the knight's move 4, Magnus said
that he was not happy with the move of the elephant 6
which leads some absolutely
surprising position is answered by white
end 3 step 1 now king c2 just
it’s impossible for a check like 4, that’s why
sun 6 respectively one step at a time
need to retreat
no matter how one black go and no sorry
something is wrong here in the sun six
you need to exchange rooks first
here is an option showed Magnus
carlsen
perry finally atrida follows check
still won't close 2 for like 4
need to move to not b1 rook d3
Fergie 1 and that's how deep I saw
world champion he is on fire here I saw that
black outcome c3 in order not to lose immediately
i have to walk
harris and 1 and then it seems to me that this is not
really liked it
it turns out the computer claims to
even here in white the chances of an advantage are well
it is clear that to go to such a position
crazy point of view yes and you can long
to discuss for a long time what other things are here
beautiful options it is clear that this is income
seems to be the only ones from the point of view
white and fergie one queen one
he is the only one there are many
alternatives in general at least this
explains that it is not in vain, as they say, they eat
your bread
participants that very much up to options
counted left behind the scenes and
actually this is to some
disappointment before happened repetition
moves seem to be in an interesting position, but
in fact, all this is quite reasonable
so these are the ideas of the center, I can still us
seen in different houses - seems to have seen seen
simple and in the final position it
attended again
couldn't play jelly one off and here's another
once again, yes, here is the camp and d2 check
king c2 queen two here before was
version of what can be put one to
run away with the king on d1 and then yes then
price 4 c3 c4 c3 has already won
festa 33 heart 3 i don't remember how it was
literally wipe it off oh yes this one is mine
option watched the words will cool
beats 3 king beat 3 until his debit
212 candy 2 no how was it
in a different way want it on reshoot ya
himself for 8 white is forced to move the king
until 4, then you don't want to change
via d5 and
take the end once refers again
mine well it's party over
ended attending the semi-finals
ended and we return to the second
semi-finals where 2 classical desks are still
continues
Levon Aronian's attempt continues
I already mentioned winning the first game in
classics vs dean move still him
a lot of time
deliberation before was pick 5 in some
moment was 40 minutes time difference
Dean made the last couple of moves
pretty fast
vnt 2 and rook h1 well, that is, right now
one of the possible development scenarios
events is to play all the same end 5 yes
and try to go for the option that we are with
you discussed
there is some thought that's as soon as we
mentioned move in 6-5 maybe his
somehow you can cook well, let's say a move
king g8 among icons same 795 looks
incredibly slow and
whites have to do something but
at least rewind
this horse to finally m already answer
marten 3 attack t5
anyway inputs at 5 hinder then
there is most likely it is too slow
send h1 need to look for something else
build batteries here this service 8 first
up to 6 to nature our one kind of special
threats
I'm looking at the next screen
I see that Almira is trying to disassemble
position with logic there is something I want
still understand which I live too
position
[music]
more than 5 mm and looking like below 5 here
let's say call what find no fadin ya
I don't know how correct it is
pick up on h3
lags beat h3 again, it seems to be forced
the first be at the same 4 now
but absolutely forced here is the rook of the same three
blacks take this to them I don't know
by the way, why am I taking this horse not to
him edward that is still there if
alternatives and by the way take ya pawn tu
he lies maybe then it seems to me
harder to deal with 5 5 in 4 it seems to me
these positions are more pleasant to play
still black is not as simple as
well, and initially and more pleasant in that to
that's the problem that black has a choice
between
such a long-term initiative where
you can, well, here are 100 moves about stomping on
place here again here if we return to
positions what specific forced
options still attracts our
attention really want to go to them and
of course, it is very important to evaluate the position
here is what I tried from them how
rate it on them sure 'bout
what specific options attract
here it is again from two different approaches
says to me it seems for someone this is
yes go to force things as well for
someone on the contrary here is a diy idea
keep the tension up what i'm here for
I judge by my style that I'm just reluctant
and I wouldn't have to convince myself that
here you need to change the nature of the position because
that in itself it is already in black
nicer can hide walk
to and fro somehow shake the defense
or go now to change
character struggle doubtful idea yes go to
aka 5-ku not h3
I think it's very important, you
you can maintain tension but without
bills still can not do very important
decide at what point exactly these
on this change of fighting character and
positions because later it can
nothing to be found, that is, it seems to me
Lebanon is thinking about this
go tips h3 don't know forced
option should white be allowed
actually the whole wall what if we
talking about it need to really u
White has some other moves there is a move
and v2 and v3 may not be the most beautiful
yes, but nevertheless they have equalities and
there is, oddly enough, a move and v2 and v4 are
move and v2 and v4 because now there is no
there are no victims on h3 already served diabetes
strokes g4 here on the same trilogy you can
such a sacrifice does not pass
respectively, if the horse returns to
e6 but somehow White protects the f-pawn
now maybe the rook f1 can
play but it changes a little
drawing yes by feeling and here scientists are here
u black get up all the same king
words and it seems to me that it is in this
position evaluation position predetermines
weakness of the king what is there for these 7 on foot
unpleasantly unpleasant whatever one may say
let's see ali minutes at least rook h4
until I understand what is
because it seems to
offhand just the outcome knight f3 yes you
chasing the rook and we can put it on our
7 but why is she standing there better tell me
that the whites are just trying to come back
why our boat is better for everyone than
rook on don't quite understand our 8
it's not clear you know maybe they can be
before maybe levon but it's a little bit
strange decision if it is completely
decide to repeat the move but for now you have
this rook happened to us h4 knight f3 rook
back horses back a little mysterious
what's going on can't Aronian not
understand that the position is absolutely I do not even
I know how much better she is
safe and yes, that is, there is no reason for blacks
go for repetition of moves just because
that they are in absolutely no danger.
relatively speaking, if the statement or
least use poker or
terminology that's flynn he's peculiar
you risk nothing
I agree that this position is still
the game is on the result of what to do with
these horses
completely incomprehensible but it seems
last chance to go to h7 now just
because after the move the rook is gone at least
rooks h8 i.e. one has every right
write down on the sheet the move knight f3 d2 and
call an arbitrator yes such agree to
draw
Well, not to be honest, it's a little
such an ending is surprising
memory and because I don't know if
be that we're just like that
made a mistake in the assessment and now Black has nothing
no i still think it's nicer
position could continue to play here
of course, you rightly noted about
what else could be on the inside
state yes i.e. did not feel in
yourself strength so to speak for a long party
aronian and maybe that's how it endures
[music]
it will probably be very difficult to know
it will be very difficult to name a favorite
will depend heavily on the
what state is any Aronian in
that he will be knocked out yes he won two
qualifying tournaments in blitz and rapid yes
in this year's grant package, but at the same time
failed performance too
well until the score is equal the score is equal after
two pairs 36 always always such a score
after two games to complete not at all
whose share
could put 93 up on the cross and even in
the second pair is also not surprising
also the score is 66, they are leaving
leave the game room
players and we what we what we will do
or our world is somehow very short
working day today turns out I think
what is there in the chat let's look at the format
draw fast and blitz well and you have
the opportunity to ask a couple of questions in the chat
this is a reminder of what awaits us
tomorrow tomorrow we are waiting for two parties in
rapid chess with control 25 minutes
delay of 10 seconds in each of these
parties
the price of victory will be four points llnui by 2
a point will be awarded to the players for a draw after which
four games in blitz yes there I am
reminded during the break still here
information that was undoubtedly worth
it was worth voicing that even if
match won all games play two
rapido and 1 blitz we plot technically
the match is over already the second second side
can't win back yes but still
all games will be played to the end and
the only clarification but it's already us
tomorrow we will do about a possible tie
break if still completely equal
score after all
after all parties with all possible
control of my time then we will already clarify
what is the tie-break format if i
I remember correctly there are two rapid games
then immediately right here
armageddon well, control and no but without
blitz and then two games in quick and
if 11 is equal, I don’t know what are there
already points are awarded immediately
party re gi dong decisive de abril
them more black time to arrange
draw
let's remember how much
our tomorrow begins he begins
no surprises just the same for all evenings
tour will begin in Moscow, which means that in 10
minutes before we start
tomorrow will be the last day
semi-finals
no matter how many of theirs they did early
or later both matches will come to some
completion let's remind
but what does a chess player still fight for
what is the prize money in this tournament for the fact that
the first prize is significant enough
defeat in the semi-finals, you see what you can
say that for the last place
chess player to receive 40 thousand dollars for
first 150 so defeat in
semi-final, let's say the final will come out
you guarantee the table defeat in the semi-finals
as long as they stay the same
guaranteed 40 which were from the very
start before losing the semi-finals
painful any lesion painful a
here it is also connected with financial
losses
well then until tomorrow what they don't
send us questions in the chat add then
let's ask our viewers yes somehow
concentrate and tomorrow we
ask as many questions as possible
though tomorrow will probably be a little more
such a tight schedule given that
that there will be quite a lot of parties, but
try to somehow tell us who
meets so the first round of the female
Grand Prix already 5 draws
they are in solidarity with the ogre so what
talked increased rumors about the appearance
tasty increased female shock okay okay
they're bantering until tomorrow we'll be very
glad to see you live
[music]